[Music]
hey what's up guys I'm cabby HD here and
this is obviously a boosted board and
this is the new boosted board mini so
I've often thought of boosted as the
Tesla of Electric skateboards and I'm
not just saying that just to find a
reason to talk about Tesla I really mean
if you think about it a lot
they were both leading the way in
electrifying their category and they're
also both really pricey and their
biggest challenge seems to be getting
that price down lower into a lower
market so if the longboard the boosted
board we've all heard and seen is kind
of like their flagship model s then this
new mini we're talking about today would
be kind of like their model 3 their most
important and cheapest yet the longboard
is fourteen hundred sixteen hundred
bucks even for the new ones which is
pretty pricey but there is nothing else
really like it but we're kind of
expecting a similar experience with the
boosted mini starting at 750 bucks so
this is your first look at the boosted
board mini and I'm no expert but I can
honestly say that I think this thing's
gonna be a pretty big deal for them also
since I'm not much of an expert I got a
lot of my observations by hanging out
with this guy obviously Casey knows
boosted boards really really well okay
okay and so his opinions help to
influence mine here
so with the new boosted board mini
obviously it's smaller but much of this
is the same as the austin boosted board
we're used to but there's just some key
differences and actually improvements so
the board first of all is 29 inches long
instead of 39 and that makes a lot of
difference as far as making it easier to
carry and bring with you places and of
course how you write it it's got this
concave shape now and it has a sloping
curve to the middle which helps you know
where to put your feet on the board
without looking it has a slight tail at
the backend kind of like a normal
skateboard and honestly I think it looks
a lot better with the grip tape and the
new logo and the black and gray just
overall a little bit stealthier it's
rockin very similar wheels to the
original boosted board but there are a
couple millimeters smaller but the
biggest difference is now in their
construction a lot of this is much
stronger material now and all the motors
and belts and trucks and overall
construction feel rock-solid right off
the bat
ride quality basically a lot of the
dampening and the control you feel when
you're on a longboard like this is from
the gap in between the wheels which has
a lot of flex this kind of acts as your
suspension system when riding around
especially at higher speeds to help you
feel more in control and stable and
smooth
boosted mini doesn't have that gap so
the battery goes all the way across
there's almost no flex at all but the
trucks are a bit looser and instead you
kind of use your foot on the back tail
as your suspension and control the board
over height so at first this sounds kind
of like a compromise but at the end of
the day it's just the difference in
riding style between a regular
skateboard and a longboard so okay
you've probably noticed by now I'm
obviously not like a veteran skateboard
rider by any means but even for me I've
noticed being smaller the mini has three
main advantages that would be carrying
turning radius and just ride style so
for carrying trying to carry the
longboard is hard there's no way around
it it's like 20 pounds it drags along
the ground unless you hold it pretty
high the mini if you just hold it
doesn't touch the ground even wanted to
loose at your side so even though it's
roughly the same weight it's immensely
easier to grab and go
then for cornering I don't know if
you've ever tried to turn a tight corner
on the boosted board but it's next to
impossible sometimes you basically end
up getting off the board adjusting it
with your hands your feet then getting
back on and going but thanks to the tail
on the mini you can kick up the front
wheels and turn kind of like a normal
skateboard I mean it's not exactly like
a normal skateboard because of all the
extra weight obviously but you can get
used to a pretty quick and you get
calibrated for how to do this really
fast even the looser trucks feel like
you can carve tighter you can still
carve on an original boosted board
obviously that's what long boards are
all about but this is just like model 3
vs. Model S there's no way around it a
shorter wheelbase means you can turn
faster and then in ride style at the end
of the day this one comes down to
preference you might prefer riding a
longboard or a short board depending on
who you are what you do what your
commute is I think there's gonna be a
lot of people like Casey that ride
around with longer commutes in the city
all the time with a lot of straight
lines and longer roads and the long
board is going to be perfect for that
but then again if you
is more like an obstacle course where
you got to go over and around things all
the time the convenience of having a
tail might beat out the style of a
longboard so there's a lot of pros and
cons a lot of ups and downs but at the
end of the day I'm excited just to see
something new from boosted who's been on
that staple that one flagship for so
long the mini is different and if I'm
being honest it's my new favorite mobile
electric skateboard I've tried a couple
others I don't ride that many but having
written this the quality is that much
better than the others I've tried and
then if I'm just trying to decide
between the mini and the regular
longboard it's just easier it's easier
to travel with it's easier to pick up
and carry a nun drop someplace if you
walk into a coffee shop or if we walk
into class or if you just want to carry
it there's just so many things that are
easier about a smaller board so I'm cool
with not having the Flex and the
suspension and learning to use that tail
because it seems to be working better
for me also you've probably noticed on
their site there is a mini s and a mini
X that looks a little bit different so
the mini s is the one we've been talking
about the orange wheels it's 750 bucks
it has a 7 mile range the mini X is kind
of like what Tesla would call the
long-range version which is a thousand
bucks and doubles the battery 14 mile
range so it's also something like 2
miles an hour faster but that's not what
you're paying for here it's the range
but either way that's it I'm pumped I'm
excited too I'm gonna make this my main
form of mobile transportation I'm
switching from the long board to it but
I'm also curious to see how some other
electric skateboard makers are going to
respond to this a lot of them have
really banked on being cheaper than the
boosted board now they have to consider
this also if you want to see a much more
talented and experienced boosted board
riders impressions of this board you can
click on case this video up here it's
really good it also won't live today but
that's about it I'm gonna wrap it up
thank you for watching tops you guys in
the next one peace